bonsoir nous sommes le 22 janvier 18h si
vous nous rejoignez en direct sur TV
fiel 78 pour cette nouvelle édition du
78 voici quelques-uns des titres qui
vont être développés au cours de la
prochaine heure une réunion de
concertation au sein du groupe Renault
une réunion qui depuis l'annonce du plan
de de 7500 départs se déroule toutes les
semaines le syndicat CGT appelle à un
débrayage d'une heure ce mercredi matin
au Technocentre à Guyancourt vous
entendrez également sur ce plateau un
représentant dessus d'un autre syndicat
à suivre donc dans quelques instants le
département des ivelines toujours placé
en niveau 2 du plan hivernal ce qui
implique des dispositifs renforcés
notamment en matière de maraude nous
avons suivi les équipes de la
Croix-Rouge départementale les
températures qui devrait encore
continuer de descendre jusqu'à -8
annoncé d'ici jeudi cela pourrait avoir
des répercussions sur la consommation
d'électricité explication à suivre avec
le réseau de transport d'électricité
basé à Montini le Bretonneux RTE une
exposition père et fils en culture à la
mairie de guillancour jusqu'au 16
février des photographies signées à
Grégoire korganov une opération réalisée
dans le cadre du cycle des paire proposé
par la ville et puis vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué une forte odeur de
gaz s répandu il ni dernière en région
parisienne un nuage non toxique en
provenance de Rouin et de son usine
spécialisée dans les additifs pour
l'odeur en question est d au mer captant
le ministère de la Santé a précisé qu'il
n'y avait pas de risque pour la santé la
préfecture des ivelines a demandé aux
ivelinois de ne pas contacter les
services d'urgence afin de ne pas
saturer les lignes de secours restez
cependant vigilant afin de détecter les
réelles fuites de gaz cette fois-ci